we're proud of you
and we're pleased to be able to present
this award to you today
yes it is a father we will send you
president
thank you very much thank you very much
dear governor dukakis my dear friend
ash thank you very much for your
incredibly friendly words
ladies and gentlemen it is indeed such
an
honor to be here with you today and
to be with you at the michael dukakis
institute for leadership and innovation
you are indeed at the forefront of
research and
debate as you could see with a glimpse
what you have just been showing
and you definitely work on some of the
world's
most pressing issues so i know that you
drive the discussion on digital policy
and how a human-centric approach
on ai could look like
and this is an issue whose importance
simply cannot be overestimated
so today i would like to speak about our
european perspective
ladies and gentlemen i am a tech
optimist
i believe that science and technology
have the power to improve our lives
indeed when i
studied to become a medical doctor i
learned for example that of course
technology
saves lives and artificial intelligence
can help identify cancers that
used to go undetected or take modern
robots
that can help to perform high precision
surgery
that used to be too risky just a few
years ago
but of course there is another side
and ash mentioned it some of us are
deeply concerned about the role
which will be left for human beings
in a world run by ai and others
worry about the serious effects that
algorithms can have
on the health of our democracies
who's taking the final decisions
who's steering the flow of information
who's deciding on rules
the world that we see through social
media platforms
seems real but of course it is
constructed
for example a list of search results
seems objective
but it is different for each and every
one of us
your google is not my google it's
steered by algorithms
thousands of likes and retweets create a
sense of unity while we literally live
in different worlds
and yes algorithms
can be a danger to our democracy but
they don't have
to be we have the power to protect
ourselves
and this is why next week the european
commission will present
its digital services act
to make sure that platforms are
transparent about the way algorithms
work and that they take responsibility
for their systemic effects
i think we cannot leave decisions
which have a huge impact on our
democracies
to systems which are black box for us
there must be at least transparency
on how the algorithm works
ai can have profound impacts on the life
of the individual
ai may influence who to recruit for a
certain post for example
or whether to grant a certain pension
application
for people to accept a role for ai in
such
decisions they must be comprehensible
and they must respect people's
legal rights just like any human
decision
maker must and this is why
we have to be able to examine the
workings of the system
and to ensure human oversight
our aim is to create an ai
ecosystem of trust
this is our european way of dealing with
ai yes
europe embraces innovation and
entrepreneurship
and yes we are eager to explore the full
potential of ai
for example for our industry and
services the health sector
but we will never lose sight of those
who are meant to benefit from these
technological wonders
our citizens our people
what sets europe apart from competitors
like china
is not the size of our tech sector
or how attractive we are for venture
capital
what sets europe apart from competitors
is the fact that our values come
first human beings come
first and
dear governor dukakis dear friend ash
ladies and gentlemen
i am so honored to receive this award
today
for me this is also a very personal
starting point
for a great new beginning between the
united states
and europe a partnership that has been
tested
time and again a partnership
that today is needed more than ever
not at least in the digital world
the way we approach algorithms and ai
will define the world we live in
and this is why the european union
proposes
to start work on a transatlantic ai
agreement we want to set a blueprint
for regional and global standards
aligned with our values
human rights and pluralism
inclusion and the protection of privacy
a transatlantic dialogue on the
responsibility of
online platforms together
we could set the blueprint for other
democracies
facing the same challenges to make sure
that algorithms and ai are a force
for good once again
i'm delighted to be with you today i'm
deeply honored by this award thank you
very much for that and thank you very
much for having me with you today thank
you
thank you so much it's good to
have us with you we look forward to
working very closely with you
and with your